[Music]
it's an essential for anyone who loves
flowers
i am a flower junkie and the jamali
garden pin frog okay so here's how it
works
first of all don't touch it it's sharp
super sharp which we learned the hard
way
yes we did so what you do is you take
your flowers and you just put the stem
onto the pins and you can do this like
ikebana
kind of floral arrangement and you could
do things that you could not
do without it you could have different
varietals different lengths
you could use a wide neck vase this will
hold your arrangement in a way that
nothing else
will i grew up in like the farm country
so we would always go out and pick
flowers and then they would just kind of
flop over i never knew what length to
cut them for the vase
well not anymore ross problem solved
thanks drew barrymore it's my pleasure
and as someone who loves flowers
i was just recently introduced to the
pen frog myself and it has changed
my life deborah we have a design
story take it away yeah this is kind of
cute this was in glamour magazine and
glamour magazine just did a story in
which they said it is time to bring back
dried flowers they are gorgeous they
bring life and color to your space you
can't go to the flower store right now
anyway because it's scary to go outside
and they never get old because they're
already dead
yes i do think that an entryway and
dried flowers or any type of flowers i'm
with you and i practice what i preach so
i did this
installation with hammer and nail that's
beautiful
thank you oh that's great what is that
that's um
on the windows there i don't know uh
but it's dry it's pretty and it's like a
deep
auburn maroon color to round out design
week
my pick is tiny but mighty it's called
the peggy wall hook
there's different shapes sizes and
multiple choices
of colors and yep these babies can hold
up to 50 pounds
and on top of all of it they look pretty
hooks
aren't always as attractive as we would
want
these are a much more adorable artistic
painterly
approach to them and i can think of a
million uses for them
in my home and yours what about you ross
well drew i'm hooked
[Laughter]
it's a must follow on instagram
at jungleo by designer justina blakeney
um i have been a long time fan i'm gonna
brag here ross
brag i was real early to this party from
the beginning
oh yeah i've been a big uh jungler and
justina fan for many years she's a huge
inspiration
and really she was a real innovator and
pioneer in this design aesthetic and
movement
well look and you can just see in these
images how much these
uh this can change the aesthetic in a
space
she really is very unique
and i think a lot of people have like
copped her style
since she launched several years ago and
she's become a huge success
and she does a lot of all of her own
hand paintings a lot of her designs come
from her
own hand and creations she's amazing
well guess what i just gave her a follow
because you told me to
so you should do it too it's the expert
an incredible new platform for design
lovers
i mean ross i'm freaking out walk me
through it okay
this is so perfect for design week so
house beautiful reports that you can now
get a one-on-one
consultation with design gurus like
leanne
ford of hgtv's restored by the ford
bobby burke
from queer eye and so many more by the
way i am
such a leon ford like psycho fan leanne
i might just have to go
online just to talk to you and
hopefully not creep you out too much um
it was co-founded by
a designer named jake arnold who's
worked with chrissy teigen and john
legend
here's the gimmick you go on if you can
do
anything from about a hundred and fifty
dollars all the way up
you know far past it but what you do for
a hundred and fifty dollars is you can
get a 30 minute consultation
with some of the biggest designers there
are in the world this
is game changing for people who would
probably never have access to that sort
of
level of design they can now get it this
is so huge and you can zoom from your
room
and they can take you through it and
help and guide you the pros
now at 150 bucks of pop what a great way
to start
[Music]